[MUSIC PLAYING]
INES ENVID: Good
morning, everyone.
It's a pleasure
to have you here.
My name is Ines Envid.
I'm a product manager in
cloud networking-- working
in many things, among others,
GKE On-Prem, part of our Anthos
announcement on [INAUDIBLE]
in this next one.
I'm going to have the
pleasure of having
with me Satya, who's the
leading engineer for GKE On-Prem
networking.
And Paul and Scott,
who we've been
working very closely on the
GKE On-Prem in the last month.
And I'll go really quick.
Because who wants to
listen to a product manager
when you've got the real people?
So let's talk a little bit
about how we're seeing the GKE
evolution, what it
means to our offering,
and why it is such an
important piece of what
we do in Google Cloud.
So you are very familiar
with containers.
You know that we've
been working on--
and the industry
in open source has
been working on
containerized applications,
and that allows us to
extract the infrastructure
of resources.
And Kubernetes really has
become in that journey
the de facto orchestrator for
the containerized applications.
So it has many advantages.
It allows to modernize
applications.
It provides the portability
so that you can actually
develop your applications.
And then you can port and deploy
very fundamental on how we
as Google see the public cloud.
And our view that it should be a
multi-cloud, it should be open,
it should be portable.
So why Kubernetes has
been so successful?
So it really provides
the capabilities
of not only orchestrating your
applications and your workload
spot, it provides
certain properties
that make it very appealing.
So you have a stable
IP for your services.
You're able to deploy your
applications within the cluster
and then provide a stable
IP and stable communication
to the external world.
But internally, the
pod IPs and the pods
that are used for serving that
application are ephemeral.
So that gives you
the flexibility
while serving the applications
to the external world
it is stable.
Now it provides you as
well with the flexibility
of delivering Layer 4 services,
delivering increased services
through our Layer
7 capabilities.
We as the implementation
of Kubernetes
have been delivering pod
IPs as first class citizens
so that they are
routable to the pods.
Now, as part of your
deployments as well,
you have the capability
of having policies.
And then you're able to declare
that certain applications are
able to communicate with others.
And those are network policies
as well as standardized APIs
that you can use for
declaring your intentions
of communicating
your applications.
And then you can do so as
well within the cluster.
Sometimes, certain
applications are
exposed to the external world,
some others that are only
made available internally,
and only through the pods
from the applications
that are meaningful
to that communication.
So now we as Google Cloud
have been delivering
solutions for Kubernetes.
Kubernetes has been a game
changer for developers.
It really provides
the de facto way
of modernizing applications.
Now obviously, it's been very
successful for developers
because all these
flexibility and portability
that it provides.
Now the issue is when you are
delivering these applications
and you are doing it for
production environments,
you still have the Day-2
operations to care about.
So you need to care about
managing the components.
You need to care about upgrading
the nodes in the cluster.
You need to care
about how to scale
in, providing high
availability, auto repairs.
And therefore, we feel that
part of the problem statement
has not really been
solved with Kubernetes.
So now what we have
been working really
hard in the last few
years is delivering
the solution for the
second part of the problem.
Now we want to deliver
a solution that
is providing the manageability
of the cluster with upgrades,
with auto repairs,
with auto scaling.
And that is really
the beauty of GKE.
It is really the solution
not only for your developers,
but also for the system
platform operators.
It really takes the
journey of Kubernetes
is from developer tool to
an enterprise-ready solution
to be deployed for your
production environments.
Now, as you can see, we've
been delivering solutions
for high availability
so then you
can have SLAs as part
of your deployments.
For example, we've been
providing high availability
not only for the cluster,
but also for the master--
with regional master so that you
can have availability in data
plane, in control plane.
We provide auto patching.
For example, taking care of
security vulnerability issues.
We provide auto repair.
We provide auto scaling.
We provide, for
example, solutions
for managed TLS certificates.
So you can think of it,
a complete end-to-end,
enterprise-ready solution.
And we really see this as a
fundamental platform for us
to deliver the capabilities
of our cloud to our customer.
So the growth of GKE in Google
Cloud has been enormous.
And we'll just see more and
more enterprises really taking
advantage of the
agility of containers
combined with the manageability
of the platform itself,
and the security
capabilities, the auto
manage capabilities that
the platform provides.
But the journey
does not end there.
We've been very busy
adding more value.
What is that value?
As we are delivering GKE as the
game changer for the platform
operator, we are doing so
not only on our platform,
but also for your
on-prem environment.
It's been really something
that many enterprises have
been asking us to do.
They want to see the
capabilities of GKE--
the manageability, the
readiness, the security--
not only for the
cloud environment,
but also for the
on-prem environments.
We're going to have
Scott and Paul talking
about why that is important.
And there are many reasons
why enterprises might not
be able to deploy certain
applications in the cloud.
But what we are doing is
providing the same principles
that we have in our
cloud in on-prem.
So what does that mean?
We mean that we are
able to provide clusters
that are able to be grouped and
able to be control and managed.
There is an
administration cluster.
There are control
plane that rounds
on-prem so that you actually
have a standalone operating
cluster on-prem whether there
is connectivity or not to cloud.
But it gets
automatically started up.
It has connectivity with the
registry that runs as well
locally so that it starts up.
And then it gets reused
there in the cloud
so that we have
the credentials, we
have the security on a single
pane of glass for visibility.
It shows in our cloud console.
And then you're able
to really manage
the functions of
your cluster as you
will do if it is in GKE in GCP.
Now it is important,
again, to note
that we understand that
the deployment needs
to be operating in on-prem.
So we've been very
careful of offering
the capabilities of running
autonomously in on-prem,
even though it has a
register to the cloud
for manageability reasons so
that we can do Up 2 upgrades.
We can actually
manage the cluster.
And the boring part is over.
So more interesting, I want
to welcome on stage Paul.
Paul Ravello is in HSBC.
He's been a very trusted
partner in all the journey.
And he is going
to talk more about
why this is important for
their deployments in HSBC.
PAUL REVELLO: Thanks.
INES ENVID: Welcome, Paul.
PAUL REVELLO: Thank you, Ines.
So hey, guys.
My name is Paul
[AUDIO OUT] HSBC.
On now?
Yeah.
Hey, guys.
My name is Paul.
I work at HSBC, an enterprise
cloud architect there.
team is responsible for
helping to set the cloud
strategy at the bank.
Typically, that means
public cloud for us.
But we are now building out
internal cloud capabilities
as well, and we've
settled on Kubernetes
to help us achieve that.
A little bit about HSBC.
We're a very large organization.
We're spread out globally.
Large number of
IT professionals,
and we have all
of the challenges
that that typically brings
in large enterprises
when it comes to
infrastructure, provisioning,
application development,
application deployment, patch
management.
So when we started
looking at this stuff,
we really had a list of items
that kind of have a long lead
time typically at the bank, and
we really wanted to fix them.
So if you look at a
standard application
deployment in our
enterprise, it's VM-based.
VM-based applications
require VMs to be deployed.
We have an IS
capability on-premise,
but it's not necessarily
a rapid provisioning.
It still has a lead
time associated with it.
It's a very static
type of provisioning.
You ask for something,
you get that something.
There's no real leeway there.
If you need something
else, you have
to ask for something else
later on down the road.
Moving to Kubernetes
and GKE On-Prem,
we can have pre-built
infrastructure that supports
the Kubernetes environment.
And then we can give
people the ability
to create images that they
can deploy there and not have
to wait for infrastructure
to be provisioned to do that.
That's a very big win for us.
It gives us the ability
to really rapidly change
the posture there.
IP allocation is a
problem that we normally
have on-premise when it comes
to infrastructure provisioning.
The reason that's an
issue for us is it's
a little bit of
a manual process,
but it's also a static thing.
IPs are tied to many things
in a typical VM application
deployment.
They're tied to DNS names.
They're tied to maybe
licensing, whatever it might be.
There's a one-to-one mapping
there of something usually.
When we go to Kubernetes and
we're running in island mode
with GKE On-Premise
specifically,
it gives us the ability
to have a wild card DNS
entry and a single
VIP on a load balancer
that all of our applications can
target that are running inside
of that infrastructure.
So you provision it once,
and it's good to go.
DNS, again, wildcard
to the cluster.
Same thing like
I just mentioned.
Rather than a manual
provisioning process for DNS,
there's a wildcard entry.
Makes things much easier to deal
with, much more faster, much
easier to deploy applications.
Configuring service--
again, typically
if you think of the lifecycle
of a VM-based application
deployment, you request the VM.
You get some information about
that VM at some point in time--
an IP address, DNS name.
You then need to go
back to in second team
and have them configure
a load balancer for you.
That's typically not
under your control
as an application developer
in a large enterprise.
That's something that
a separate team handles
on the infrastructure side.
This eliminates that because
you're now just using
the ingress controller that's
built into the Kubernetes
environment.
It's all handled as part of
your application deployment--
very simple, very
straightforward.
Having a high availability
control plane.
This is an interesting
one for us.
We're in financial services.
HA is very important to us.
Getting HA for every piece
of your infrastructure
that supports your application
deployments is a challenge.
It's expensive.
Moving to Kubernetes kind
of solves that a little bit.
And with GKE On-Premise
specifically, we
have the ability to have
highly available masters that
are separate from the actual
user clusters themselves.
This is great for us.
It gives us the ability to scale
that independently, provide
high availability
there independently
from the applications
that are running it.
Day-2 operations-- Ines,
touched on this a little bit.
But this is a little
bit more specific
to the actual
application deployments.
So patches and
upgrades-- if you think
about VMware-based deployments,
how do you patch a VM?
You have to patch a VM, right?
Well, now you have 100,000 VMs,
you have to patch 100,000 VMs.
Upgrades-- same thing.
You want to do an OS upgrade?
That's a major, major challenge
in a large enterprise.
With GKE On-Premise--
Kubernetes, in general--
you can do customer-initiated
auto upgrades of the Kubernetes
environment that have already
been tested and approved
by Google.
It's not something that
you need to necessarily do
automatically.
We're an enterprise.
We wouldn't necessarily
want something
to upgrade automatically
behind the scenes for us,
but it can be
customer-initiated.
There's a button that
you can click to say
I want to upgrade right now.
I want to upgrade at this time.
Works very well for us.
Reshaping infrastructure--
I touched on this before.
If you request a VM in a
typical enterprise, it's a VM.
If you need that changed--
if you need more
memory, more CPUs
allocated, more disk
space-- what do you do?
You have to submit
another request.
It might be self-service,
but there's still
probably an approval
process there.
And there's a timing thing.
Well, with
declarative intent, we
can put people in
a namespace that
has certain quotas
associated with it.
They can deploy what they
want to their heart's content
in that namespace,
use their resources,
and reshape their
infrastructure that they're
running their application
in up to their quota.
And the quota itself can
be a little bit easier
to enable self-service for.
Works very well, again.
Resizing services-- in
a typical deployment,
with VMs, if you add
another VM to the service,
you have to contact that
load balancer team again,
have them add the IP
of the VM to the load
balancer for that application.
It's not a seamless thing.
It's not quick to do.
With auto scaling, that
happens naturally-- built
into Kubernetes.
control plane visibility-- this
is another really interesting
one for us.
If you think about a
typical infrastructure
in an enterprise, many
different components,
many different vendors.
Getting all of that
information in one place
typically relies
on another tool.
You either need some kind
of a sim or a log aggregator
to get all of that information
in one place to be able to use.
And even then, it's really
never perfect right.
With GKE On-Prem, all of the
logs for the infrastructure
that's supporting all
of the applications that
are running there
are sent very nicely
into Snapdragon over a tether.
Works very well.
Troubleshooting and
logging-- a little bit more
like control plane
visibility, but this is
more on the application side.
In a typical
enterprise, it can be
very difficult to give
individual application
owners access to metrics related
directly to their applications.
In Kubernetes, in
GKE On-Prem, we
have really advanced tooling
with Prometheus and Grafana.
It's very simple to
create custom dashboards
per application with
RBAC wrapped around them.
Individual application
teams can see
what they need to
see to understand
how their applications are
behaving from a CPU and memory
perspective, a
network perspective.
And we have Stackdriver
for actual application
logs if that is what's
chosen to be utilized.
And as mentioned that
we've been working closely
on a lot of this
stuff, and we have.
And I think that, at
the end of the day,
all of the work that
we've done together
has created a really
compelling package
to have an enterprise
deployment of Kubernetes that's
really scalable.
It works really
well, and we're very
happy with all the integrations
that have been done so far.
With that, I'm going
to hand it over
to Satya, who's
one of the people
that we've been working
very closely with.
And he's been great
with us, working
on all of the networking
components inside the product.
SATYADEEP MUSUVATHY:
Thank you, Paul.
And I have Scott
joining me on stage too.
So I'm going to start out
by thanking Paul and Scott
because they've been
working with us from get-go,
quantifying a lot
of these problems
and actually educating us a
lot on what actually works.
Because when we
started GKE On-Prem,
we kind of recognized
that you understand
your network the best.
It's not the cloud.
You have your own constraints
on how you build the networks.
You have your own
constraints on what works,
and why it is the
way it is today.
And our goal here was
to go in and actually
adapt GKE and Kubernetes to
work best in your environment
with minimal overhead in
terms of networking cost.
That was the way we
thought about the problem.
And HSBC has helped us a lot
in actually making that work
and making that actually
doable in some sense.
And so when we started
out, what we did was
we had to start with
some principles.
How do we think
about this problem?
And when we did it in terms of
these five or six principles.
So the first thing
we wanted to do
was we wanted to support
native Kubernetes
constructs as much as possible.
So we didn't want to
go in and say, oh,
because you want to expose
something as a web service,
go do this other thing after
you deploy Kubernetes service.
We wanted you to be able
to use Kubernetes Ingress.
We didn't want to make anything
that was Google-specific
or GKE On-Premise specific.
We want to support
Kubernetes where it mattered.
That was the grounding
principle on which we
approached the whole problem.
The second thing we
did was we didn't
want to yet another overlay.
There are enough overlays in
these network environments.
And we didn't want to yet
another overlay as much
as possible.
But in order to be
able to support that
and to be able to support
multiple applications
without having to expose
IPs for everything,
we decided to separate
L4 from L7 load balancing
and ship L7 load balancing
as an in-built service
within the cluster.
So if you've used GKE
or used any cloud,
think about it as you
kind of assume HTTPS load
balancing happens for you.
And then you assume there's
a service that doing that.
We wanted to give you that same
experience with GKE On-Prem.
So when you want
to get started out,
you shouldn't have to think
about how L7 will work.
It should just work.
And the last thing is
having done the separation,
we picked an Envoy-based
L7 load balancer,
but then decided to integrate
with your existing L4
solutions in your
network so that you
don't have to kind of invent
yet another technology for how
you want to do L4.
So these were the
grounding principles
of how we approached the
problem, how we broke it down.
And as we look into each
of the details of how
we do control plane and
data plane in the following
slides, but those
were the principles.
And as you see--
through these slides,
you'll see how they actually
play a role in how
the solution evolves.
The very first thing, as
Ines was pointing out,
was how the control plane
itself tethers back to Google.
So if you think about it-- and
this was one of the very first
insights that we had--
most people just think
On-Prem and Google Cloud,
and they think
that's two networks.
Well actually, we sat
back and looked at it.
It's actually three networks.
There is your On-Prem network.
There is your Google Cloud
network, which is a VPC.
And then there is the
actual prod network
that Google's back
services run on.
And they're three
distinct networks.
And you own in some sense
your on-prem network
and your view of the cloud VPC.
It's your network because
it's [INAUDIBLE] project.
The other stuff is
Google-hosted project--
Google stuff.
So when we wanted
to tether in, we
assumed that we will have to
support multiple [INAUDIBLE]
from get-go.
Like I said, we want it
to adapt to what you have.
So there's two ways that the
tether will actually work.
It could dial out
to an Egress proxy
that you have in your network--
because assuming you're
all close networks.
And then do an SSL
tunnel back so you
can get a secure end-to-end
connection on how your control
plane gets visibility on
Pantheon and your Google Cloud.
Or you could actually go in and,
if you have an interconnect,
connect through the
interconnect, which
will route traffic
through your VPC
and stay completely
private to your enterprise
and never have to go
through the public internet.
So there's two
modes that you can
use to actually go in and
register your clusters
into the cloud so you
can do all the management
of your workloads, the
marketplace access, and things
like that.
Now, what is it that is
registering it, right?
So what is the control plane
in itself looking like?
So one of the things
that we wanted to do
is why do we only tether a
control plane back and not
run the control plane remotely?
We wanted to use the ability
to be able to manage and run
the control plane even
if you, let's say,
loose internet connectivity.
This is your on-prem network.
As long as your
on-prem network is up,
you should be able to
manage your clusters.
And the way we did that is
by A, separating the control
plane from the user plane,
running a cluster just
for the control plane-- we
call this the admin cluster.
We host the workloads
for your user clusters
masters in the admin cluster.
And then we let the nodes that
are there for the user cluster
run just the workloads,
which is its own network.
If you actually step
back and think about it,
this is exactly
what you get in GKE.
Google manages
your master on GKE.
You get a bunch of nodes,
which is the user cluster
nodes that you scale
for your workloads.
You get the exact same
experience in GKE On-Prem,
except that the admin cluster
itself is hosted locally.
It builds on the same concepts,
and it exposes an L4 IP.
And the user cluster nodes are
completely for user workloads,
and they just register
back to their master
to do their operations.
And we make all the wiring work.
And this then says--
essentially what
it does is you run
GKE CTO to create a cluster.
You get something in the admin
cluster for your manager.
And then you get all
the workloaders spun up,
and we go in and give you
a kubeconfig file pointing
to the master API.
And you can just do cube
ctl apply at that point,
and your workloads will then
run on the user cluster.
So that's the networking flow.
And in order to solve
this, we actually went in
and had to solve a
bunch of problems.
And at this point, I'm going
to hand it over to Scott
to talk about--
Scott actually influenced
a lot of these decisions
and why they were valuable.
And he'll talk
about these choices.
SCOTT SUROVICH: Great, great.
Thank you, Satya.
So as Ines said earlier,
we've been working with them
for about a year now on this.
So when they first came
to us with the product
it was pretty Google
opinionated on certain things
that didn't fit with what
we need in the enterprise.
And one those first things
is that first bullet point,
which is the static IPAM.
So we also wanted to use
our own load balancers.
Still NF5, could
be something else.
But in order to use that the way
we have to use it internally,
we needed static IPs.
Those are in a pool, so we can
still kind of leverage them.
I'll call it dynamic static IPs.
So we can still scale out
the clusters as needed.
So it went from being
DHCP-based only into a option--
so static which is
populated through a file.
So as Satya was saying,
one of the big advantages
we have here, when we started
our journey on Kubernetes,
we looked at every flavor
you could possibly think of.
If we were to do multiple user
control planes for, let's say,
business, we would have multiple
masters all over the place.
In this case, we have
our single up there.
All the user control planes,
I think as Satya was saying,
run inside there in
their own namespace.
And that has your API
server, your etcd servers.
And they are all in an HA mode.
That eliminates multiple
VMs that we do not
have to create, maintain,
patch, get IPs for.
So down there, it's
up to currently,
I believe, 10 is what
it's going to be Satya.
SATYADEEP MUSUVATHY:
Thanks, Scott.
And that kind of wraps up how
we thought about the control
plane, and essentially
give you the same flavor
of GKE's management
on on-prem networks,
giving the same separation
of basically administrator
management being independent
of the user workload management
and to be able to do each
of these independently.
And I will start
taking a look at how
the data plane itself works.
So you've got the cluster up.
You want to deploy
your workload on it.
How do we actually
expect it to work?
Before we go into how
the networking works,
this is kind of like
a context of the way
we were trying to meet.
You have your on-prem
cluster, and you
wanted to apply some
microservices on it.
And you want to expose
it through some name.
And clients in your network--
this is not like clients
out in the internet--
in your on-prem prem network--
are trying to access each
of these internal services.
And these services,
in some sense,
might want to reach outside the
cluster to talk to, let's say,
an existing data store or
an existing backup service
that you want to use and
exposed within the cluster.
As we looked at
this picture, there
were like three main
requirements that bubbled up.
The first is from a
security perspective
and from just an IP
utilization perspective,
the ability for pod IP is
not being directly reachable
from the on-prem network.
It came out something
that's valuable.
So if you look at a Kubernetes
cluster, you're, let's say,
looking at 110 parts per node.
So you want to do a
slash 24 per node.
You want basically
eight to 10 nodes,
you'll now start looking
at slash 20, slash 80,
and outer spaces.
And finding these
contiguous outer spaces
start becoming really,
really hard when you
have disjointed outer spaces.
So by actually not having
pod IPs directly exposed,
you can reuse these
outer spaces and not
worry about losing outer spaces
in your on-prem environment
to actually bring up a cluster.
You're just using an IP
for the envelope balancer
and IP for the
nodes, and that's it.
So it looks exactly like how
you would deploy iteration
application, except
for that cost
of a traditional application you
get a full Kubernetes cluster.
So those are the first drivers
behind our networking model--
the starting networking model.
Which leads to the second
point, which is essentially
what I was talking about,
limited number of IPs
exposed to an L4 load balancer.
I recommend doing a
wildcard DNS match.
So essentially you
want to be able to do
name-based routing instead
of IP-based routing
once your traffic
hits the cluster.
And, finally, as Scott
was also mentioning,
we gave the ability
not just to DHCP,
but actually a bag of
static IPs that you
can give to the
cluster creation tool
and say, manage my nodes IPs
within this, which it lets you
then preconfigure
your load balancer,
or if you want to use
your own existing load
balancers to that
shared service.
Because you know what
the back ends are.
You are basically
telling the cluster use
these IPs for the nodes.
So that's the context behind how
we thought about the problem.
Scott?
SCOTT SUROVICH: So,
as Satya was saying--
or as Paul was also
mentioning, when
we have a new service
come in, you've
got to get your IP address.
You've got to get your DNS.
And something we
didn't really mention
is certificates
for that service.
Everything has to be encrypted.
So with this model,
as Satya was saying,
we limit it to three IPs.
So we're going to
need off-the-bat--
it can be expanded,
but it's going
to be three of the Envoy-based
Ingress controllers.
So we use a wildcard
DNS to come in.
And from there, we also
use a wildcard certificate.
So our developers
can spin up anything
that's going to be
on a Layer 7 base
and instantly have access to it.
And they'll do this for
a test site as well.
So they'll have site
A do their works.
Site B, different
selector on the Ingress.
And they can suss
out an application
and cut things over in a
pseudo kind of AB deployment.
And in the middle there, what
we talk about the Ingress.
It might be important
to mention, Satya,
that we're not
stuck with just one.
It does support
multiple Ingresses.
So Envoy-based shipping with it.
But if you want to put
Nginx in there as well,
you can do that for other
annotations that you might need
or other features for any
other Ingress controllers.
SATYADEEP MUSUVATHY:
Thanks, Scott.
And in order to make that
work, what we had to do
was how do we make the
pod IPs in a way that
meets the Kubernetes model.
Which, as Ines was pointing out,
assumes a flat IP address space
for pods within a cluster,
which is if pod A wants
to talk to pod B, you assume
they can directly reach
each other within the cluster.
But we also said we
don't want to expose
pod IPs outside the cluster
just to save on the IP space.
So what we did is we essentially
built a node-to-node BGP mesh,
which announces the slash 24
that's allocated to each node
for the pod IPs so
that they become--
basically, you don't need an
overlay to load the pod IPs.
The underlying
network will actually
route the pod IPs directly.
But since we never announced the
BGP routes outside the cluster,
they essentially form what
we call an island of IPs
within the cluster.
But then this leads
to the problem
that if a pod wants to talk to
an external database, how will
the traffic work?
What we do is if you're pod IP
is reaching outside the cluster
but it's not intended
to another pod IP,
you hit the node boundary.
We basically [INAUDIBLE]
by the nodes IP on Egress.
And that way the returned
route will actually
work with connection tracking,
which essentially then
gives you an island
of large IP space.
You can use slash
14 if you want,
that you can just reuse
between each clusters
because they never leak
outside the cluster.
And the only cost you pay is
the actual node IPs themselves,
which is function of the
number of nodes in a cluster.
So this is the first thing.
And now given this
cluster, we look
at how the traffic flow works.
The way the traffic flow
works is, as Scott was saying,
you start with a
wildcard DNS entry
that you mapped to
an Ingress service.
We ship an ingress
service out of the box.
If you go through a
GKE On-Prem install,
it'll ask you what IP to
associate for the Ingress
service.
So you are actually telling
the system what IP to use.
But you can then configure
the environment to say here's
a wildcard DNS entry that
maps to that Ingress IP.
So, let's say, start
out a.b.c to make
it a little more
concrete, and a client
wants to reach your
service S1.a.b.c.
So the wildcard DNS
in your environment
that you configured
once will basically
point it to the L4
load balancer on which
that web was configured.
The L4 load balancer will
then your standard Kubernetes
NodePort back ends to
send that traffic down
to one of the nodes in your
cluster to it's NodePort.
At which point, again,
standard Kubernetes takes over,
sends that traffic
down to the Envoy part
that we are running for
the Ingress service, which
is essentially a subset of STOs
Pilot and Envoy combination.
This is for [INAUDIBLE] traffic.
And it's hits that pod.
At which point,
essentially all of this
is just control
plane [INAUDIBLE]..
Envoy looks at the L7 header.
It looks at the hostname.
It looks at the pod.
You can deploy a standard
service with a clusterIP.
These are IPs in the cluster
that never reached out.
And add a Kubernetes
Ingress object
that says either a pod-based
match or a hostname match,
send to our service.
And the Envoy basically
then proxies it down
to your service.
So, essentially, what this
gives you is an ability
to deploy services with names
within the wildcard DNS name
pattern without losing any
additional IPs for each service
that you put in.
And you scale out
the service, scale
in service within the cluster.
Or let's say, as Scott
was saying, your service
itself could be Nginx itself.
If you want to do your
own custom configuration,
all you have to do is to say,
here's the hostname match,
send it to my Nginx
pod or service,
and all your configurations
will work end-to-end.
So you can essentially
scale out your system
by having additional services
come in and be able to route
just by hostnames
within the cluster.
And your IP cost
into the network
is just that L4 Ingress IP
for 90% of your use cases.
And we also recognize
there our other use cases
where you can directly use
service type load balancer.
But most cases you
shouldn't have to
if you're just
doing microservices.
Scott?
SCOTT SUROVICH: Yeah,
and the important thing
about when this gets set up--
so those NodePorts
you might be thinking
you have to statically
assign those over on the F5s.
Let's say, OK, if
you're looking for this,
you're going to go down to this
pod over here on this NodePort.
There's the F5 controller
pod installed by default.
That handles all this for you.
So when it does get
installed, as Satya is saying,
you basically just asked for
a couple questions-- a couple
being like 20, but still.
And it just goes off and
deploys in about 30, 35 minutes.
And at that point your
wildcard DNS will work.
You've got your pods running,
your NodePorts running.
And as Satya said, you're
saving all those addresses,
which is a big win
for us, obviously,
at the scale that
Paul showed you.
That's a lot of IP addresses.
And that doesn't count
what's over on our load
balancers, what's
behind the scenes,
or what's just internal
to certain other clusters.
So all this just helps our
developers basically do
their CI/CD go from nothing to
a full app in 15, 20 minutes--
whatever they happen to have--
and everything is running.
So this has been very
well received internally
by our application developers.
Just on the installation that
we have installed for Kubernetes
in general, we had probably
about 115 unique namespaces
within about two or
three months of use.
And the feedback we're
getting from people--
all of our developer
community has always
been positive and the speed.
SATYADEEP MUSUVATHY: But then
if you realize-- if you actually
sit down and think about it,
routing inside the cluster
we've assumed is free.
We've said we've created
a mesh of all pod IPs.
We've assumed all pod IPs
[INAUDIBLE] all pod IPs,
which, if you're
a security person,
would start kind of
causing some form of worry.
Because how do I then protect.
Because, as we've
said, we want to have
multi-tenancy in some sense
between multiple services.
We want to host it
within a cluster.
They're all routing
through the Envoy pod.
And how do we lock it down?
And so recognizing that,
and, as it's stable space,
in most environments, we do
ship network policies out
of the box.
So any service, any
service-to-service pod-to-pod
communication you can lock
it down based on your intent.
So, you can say, for example
in the previous slide,
you could potentially
say I have service S1,
but that's only
reachable, let's say,
from the Istio service
for the Envoy pod
and not by any other
service within the cluster
if you wanted to.
Or the back info service one is
only reachable by service one.
And so even if somebody wanted
to write an Ingress rule that
said expose it as a new
name, the network policy
won't even the traffic
down to that service.
So these are supported
out of the box.
Scott?
SCOTT SUROVICH: Yeah,
the network policies
have been a big request
from our developer community
for alternate solutions in
[INAUDIBLE] environments
or even in full VM mode.
And it's very difficult,
especially in a full VM
mode to let a developer
log in and say, OK,
this server can only
go to A, B, or, C.
So it's been
something that we've
needed for a very long time.
And I know we have some
of our security people
in this room actually.
So I know this is something
that they're very happy about.
So it gives the developer the
ability to configure this.
It's just standard Kubernetes
network policies, which
many of you have probably seen.
So you can control your
Ingress and your Egress
based on protocol,
IPs, destinations.
So this is something
that we've been
asked by a lot of our
businesses on how am I
going to secure this.
And I did mention on
the previous slide
that we have 120,
130 namespaces.
So obviously, multi-tenant
is one of our concerns.
This is something that helps
to secure that multi-tenancy.
So we can have only the
applications talking to what
they should be talking to.
So, with that, what
we're going to do--
I'm going to hand it
back over to Ines.
Paul and myself will be
available for any kind
of questions that you have on
the enterprise portion of this.
And I think Satya and
Ines will [INAUDIBLE] some
of the GKE-based portions.
INES ENVID: Thank you, Scott.
As you see, there's a lot
of passion in the team.
There's a lot of knowledge.
I just want to wrap up
with a couple of thoughts.
First, I want to thank you--
the HSBC team for
their partnership.
I truly mean this.
We have been working on a
solution that truly fits
their needs as an enterprise.
And in doing so, we
have ensured as well
that we provide the most
stringent, highly available,
secured solution that
meets the enterprise needs.
And we would not have been
able to do that without them.
It's been a relatively short
journey for what this delivers.
We've been iterating
really fast.
We have been leveraging, of
course, a lot on the technology
knowledge expertise
that we have in-house,
and really bringing all
that goodness on-prem.
So this really gives
you the solution
that really mimics the
Google Cloud GKE solution.
That it's really kind of the
state-of-the-art for managed
Kubernetes solution
for enterprises.
[MUSIC PLAYING]